thursday edition of pftot
before we set loose chris sims on the
weekend the three-day weekend you've
woo-hoo you haven't had to enjoy it you
haven't gotten a three-day weekend the
last three weeks because we
we've it's been a 21-day weekend yeah
um but but i remember we did the math i
had more days off than you because i
worked five days
right so i ended up paying for it
because the nfl was busier than ever
during the supposed slow time
yeah so it's like we weren't even off at
all so anyway we're playing in the toy
department we love doing what we do
chris would love to work on friday but
he's contractually prohibited from doing
so
or something anyway let's get to it
before we we we uh uh
uh just completely bore everyone to
death no
training camp visits by officials this
year that was announced yesterday by the
nfl
you throw that because my first thought
was hey
no preseason games no problem just just
let the officials get their feet wet
working scrimmages or whatever at camp
like they always do
the league slams the door on that chris
the officials are bad enough when
they're actually prepared
i mean you could say on one hand they're
not going to be much worse
on the other end you can say they could
be a hell of a lot worse
since they have no preparation before
week one no i i
i'm a little like you know when i first
saw it i was like oh yeah of course they
did yeah yeah that's right i mean you
know why would they want to
you know chance that or do that or get
you know i i get it
but also at the same time you know my
mind then went to
well wait why why can't they have
referees at practice
you know they can stand in their
positions and certainly be away from
everybody i like you like your point
you're making it certainly would help
them they need the reps too without
pre-season seeing the speed of the game
yeah that would scare me as a coach in
week one with a bunch of referees coming
out there and like
whoa we haven't seen you know some of
them haven't seen live action
sports you know since december because
they didn't get to coach in the playoffs
but also i think it would help the
players too just to make the adjustments
that are necessary through training camp
so i guess you know i'm surprised a
little bit but i'm not surprised and i
guess
the the real thing is why risk it be as
careful as can be right now
and it's going to be more on the coaches
to make sure and this is not
easy because coaches let this thing lets
this stuff slide too much in training
camp through my history in the nfl i
would say is
you know not holding their players
accountable to oh you can't do this this
is illegal blah blah blah sometimes we
just go oh
you know the coaches just go oh we ran
the play right nobody messed up their
assignment
you have a coach but there was four
holdings on the offensive line no one's
gonna say anything about that
and that's where it's gonna be on the
coaches to be a little more strict with
that this year
but you make a great point chris and i
want to emphasize it because it's such a
rare dynamic
the the idea that that why shouldn't
they be at practice
why can't they be at practice i mean
we're going to expect these officials
who will be
wearing masks i think i saw i mean it's
a given the officials are going to wear
masks right in the games right
so the first time you ever actually do
it the first time you set foot onto a
field in the pandemic in an empty
stadium in any setting to have any reps
at all
is in a game that counts are you kidding
me like what the
the players are going to practice why
not have
officials there for a day even if it's
just a day
it can make a huge difference you know
the the players will be out on the field
in practice the the officials get tested
get sequestered pass or you know two
tests two negative tests before they let
you show up at practice whatever the
case may be
why wouldn't you want to give them some
sort
of of help some sort of
preparation for what is going to be the
craziest most upside down season they've
ever encountered and then
the pressure right out of the gates with
everything else all the worries about
the virus
on top of all of that because for them
it's a road game every week
right right they're always traveling to
the game
site they don't get to just drive from
their house to the stadium
they're going to have stress every week
they're going to have concern every week
and if they start off with bad calls and
it's our obligation to point out when
they're bad calls we're not going to say
oh poor referees didn't have a chance to
to get ready for the season bad calls or
bad calls and uh i think they really
need to consider whether there's a way
to get these folks better prepared yeah
a hundred percent agreed
and you know that that's what i think
about because now you go into like week
one
you know like you're saying where yeah
they're they're getting used to whoa
okay new mechanics and nobody's in the
stands and we haven't done this in a
while and i haven't seen players
and to me it's gonna lead to one of two
things
in week one in the nfl we're gonna
either see
over-officiated games and way too many
flags
or we're gonna see the refs go oh i'm
not sure what i'm seeing right now and
there'll be nothing called and they're
gonna let everything go
and that'll be interesting to see where
that that goes and
and if teams can kind of catch on to
that early in the game like hey these
refs aren't calling anything guys
hey dbs they're calling nothing just use
your hands a little more
don't be afraid to be aggressive with
your hands these guys are they're being
very liberal letting it all go whatever
you know i i think you know that's
another aspect to think about when it
comes to week one to where
you know your refereeing could be all
over the place
and remember they are going well they
were
you know i just thought of something uh
they were going to experiment
with this concept of expanded
booth involvement from the replay level
at the stadium during the pre-season
with no pre-season there goes that i'm
going to ask the nfl about that as soon
as we're done here but
i i i you know that number one would be
very helpful
to have some support for the officials
on the field from the replay official or
the league office but i think the
thing's doa if there's no preseason
right
yeah that's when they were going to
experiment with it if it all went well
they were going to incorporate it into
the
into the regular season well i mean so
i'm just it's led me to believe too do
they have a fail-safe plan in case some
of these refs also get come down with
kova 19 or something like that
yeah they do they're ready to go with as
few as five
okay as few as five right so i don't
know what happens if there's fewer than
five i mean if it's basketball
you go ahead and play with four i i
think there's a
and and look i i would not have i
generally have no problem with the
league using
the pipeline from 345 park avenue
to the stadiums to help support the
officials
as long as you get the calls right do it
right here i understand
certain games are going to benefit more
from it than others you got nine games
being played at once
it's going to be hard to help
stand-alone games night games playoff
games
big games thanksgiving games whatever go
ahead go ahead and help them out
why make it harder than it is to be do
what you got to do to get the calls
right let's not
tolerate human error and simply say oh
well it's a pandemic you got to deal
with more human error that's not going
to be good
for anybody if it happens all right
another thing that won't be good for
some of the teams out there and we saw
the video
of the vikings facility peter king went
there last week i guarantee you if this
was three or four years ago
they would not have welcomed peter king
to the facility because the vikings
would have had a hell of a time
getting winter park their old practice
facility
ready to comply with the rules of the
pandemic right and chris
you've heard some chatter about this not
every team facility is state of the art
there's some old crappy buildings out
there
they may have a hard time accommodating
everything they need to do
to get ready for the 2020 training camp
and regular season yeah well and
i think you know if i've gotten a
complaint from
you know and then the reason i brought
this up before we started this was
because yeah it's
over the last two or three weeks i've
had four different coaching friends from
four different teams kind of bring this
up about
their facilities they don't know how
this is going to work or
thank god we have a new facility and we
can
you know make this happen but i do think
there's a little bit in the coaching
world
like a concern for oh this team since
they have a new facility they have a
little bit of an advantage where
you know if you're in an older facility
and some of the rules and the amount of
guys that are allowed in each meeting
room
and then the team meeting room there's
lack of resources
and some teams you know they don't have
a ton of practice fields they might only
have
two there's not a lot of outdoor area to
separate things
people and things like that so i think
it's a very real concern with some of
the teams that have the older facilities
listen i played for a team in the
tennessee titans
where it was a good facility certainly
but not new or state of the art and i
think about them right now and go
oh i don't how are they going to make
all these meetings work with 80 guys and
do
all that type of stuff it's just
something interesting to think about
let alone i had one coach complained to
me about you know it's not fair with
some of the teams who have their
facilities uh connected to their stadium
because now they can use their stadium
as well visiting locker rooms
suites things like that where you know
if they can level that off to where it
fits in the covid 19 bubble for the
facilities that those teams are going to
have
of course a little bit more leeway and
room to have meetings and walk throughs
and do that
and i think some of the other teams that
have these smaller outdated facilities
are a little concerned like the chargers
i you know that's one i think about what
the hell the chargers gonna do
how they gonna make that work their
facility's not up to date yet so there's
a few out there that i know are a little
bothered by this situation
yeah steelers are using heinz field
instead of their practice
exactly on the north side of pittsburgh
because there are four locker rooms
there because
pitt plays their home games there the
giants
are doing training camp out of metlife
stadium the jets are going to be at
their regular facility
the giants facilities close enough where
they can use their practice fields but
the hub is going to be
the multiple locker rooms whether they
use the jets locker room or not i think
remains to be seen but they can do
meetings in the suites yeah
and why not if why not use
the stadium uh because the stadium has
to be set up anyway
to comply with the rules of the pandemic
right so instead of doing the stadium
and the facility
just do the stadium and use the stadium
and chris the other thing too
i think every new stadium and every new
facility
moving forward is going to have to be
designed
taking into account the possibility this
is going to happen again yeah it may
never happen
again right but you're an idiot if you
don't plan
for it when you design your new stadium
and when you design your new facility to
make it easy
to basically press a button and you know
lockers can be moved and this can be
done and it's not this major undertaking
and and i you know we hear about the
teams that are having rookies show up
early and
you know that i know of at least one
team
that is not having anybody show up until
the 28th and it hasn't been reported yet
as to which team it is
but uh they're busting their asses to
get everything ready
you know this is not an easy thing to do
and i think what should be encouraging
for vikings fans
is they were sufficiently proud of where
they are with their with their
uh effort to comply with the rules of
the pandemic that they opened it up to
peter last week because if it was not
anything to be proud of there's no way
in hell any team is letting an outsider
in to go walk around and see what a mess
it is
no i i agreed you're right i mean
they're just you know
it's the thing that keeps coming up with
guys i text with
in the nfl every there's just so many oh
what about if this happens what about
that happens there's so many things that
are still
not figured out and like you're saying
yeah well
okay even if guys this is where i i
don't know if the season can start on
time because even if like
you know you start on the 28th or
whatever it may be
it's gonna be a few days before
everybody's allowed to practice and
oh we got all the test results back and
everything so it's not like you're going
to get there on the 28th like you were
in the old days or last year
and then go oh we're practicing on the
29th now you're going to get there the
28th
and it's going to be probably four five
six days before guys can even get on the
field
because of these protocols and things
like that let alone
you know a lot of these coaches don't
even know what the protocols are
completely yet as far as the rules and
what they're going to be allowed and not
allowed to do so uh there
there's a lot of different angles to
think about and
you know added to the fact too hey if
you're a head coach mike
here's another one that came up in text
uh a few weeks ago
you know if you're a head coach at some
point you know you need to have a
scrimmage to get
football going but you might need to do
something like that too because
hey you're the head coach you could get
covered 19. who's going to coach your
team if you're not there
you know these are all there's so many
circumstances like that that are very
interesting
you got to have somebody you ready to
hand the whistle to you're absolutely
right
you need to be thinking about it you may
want to practice that yeah along the way
you may want to do it with two guys
because there's a chance that right the
guys you spend the most time with
may be positive if you end up positive
as well i was talking to somebody this
week and
you know we agreed that you could sit
down
and come up with 900 things that need to
be
worried about as it relates to football
and a pandemic and in the process of
identifying
900 things you would think of 900 more
things
this is something jc tretter the nflpa
president said a few weeks ago and it's
something we had said before that
every question that you answer spawns at
least
three more questions and then you answer
those and it spawns three more questions
for each of those answers and it keeps
going and going and going and
you know that's why i think the patriots
are going to be fine this year because i
think the one guy
best suited to answer the questions
anticipate the questions
answer those questions and have a plan
that will be
bulletproof and foolproof is is bill
belichick and speaking of belichick tom
brady
after 20 years of playing for bill
belichick takes his talents
to tampa bay and it was noteworthy on
sunday when all of the big name players
began
hammering the nfl on social media but
not including tom brady and i thought at
the time maybe they specifically avoided
tom brady chris because
tom brady has kind of been undermining
the broader mission of the nflpa by
defying the recommendation that players
not engage in group workouts before
training camp
which also makes it harder for the nflpa
to take a hard line in negotiations with
the league
because when you see tom brady and his
teammates practicing
people involved on the league side of
the equation look at it and say these
guys aren't worried about the virus
we don't have to bend on these these
issues that nflpa leadership is
is bothering us about because at the end
of the day they're just going to accept
whatever we say and show up because look
at what tom brady's doing so
three days after the fact brady shows up
on twitter there are more questions and
answers but we must have faith in our
nflpa leaders both players and staff
to get the game and the business of
football in the right place let's stay
unified and demand necessary answers
from the nfl as partners we're all in
this together
again first of all he's three days late
which makes it conspicuous
second of all he defied what the union
was recommending and there's so many
people say well it wasn't a hard and
fast rule there's no enforcement no
but they said don't do it i don't care
if he can get in trouble for it or not
they said don't do it and he did it he
gave the union the middle finger he
undermined the union's effort to try to
keep players safe
and send a cohesive message to the
league and now he's showing up three
days after the fact
banging this drum over let's demand
you know necessary answers from the
league uh he's the wrong guy to be
pushing that message yeah well i mean i
i hear you you're right i mean i i
i totally get what you're saying you
know but i i
you know i also have compassion for the
the player and the competitor too
because you know i'm not going to sit
here and say that i would be much above
maybe tom brady and some of the antics
that he's pulled off during this
pandemic i mean i know i've stated many
times
26 or 27 year old chris sims wouldn't
give a damn about this
and you know you when you're as
obsessive
as a lot of these great football players
are and especially a guy like tom brady
and he knows that this might be his last
year or two more years
it is a tough thing to juggle here
because he wants to be ready he wants to
be
he wants to be great and i really
respect that about tom brady
i mean he lays it out there every
off-season
and you know this is a difficult one but
you're right i mean
i guess what i'm i'm saying is i wish
brady just your right didn't even send
out that tweet or say anything because
it seems a little hypocritical that he's
trying to say that right now
but uh you know i'm gonna sit here and
not deny i i would totally probably have
done some of the same things tom brady
did if i was in this situation so
i i do have a lot of competition hang on
yeah i know you well enough to know yeah
that you would not
have posted on social media social media
didn't exist
you're right we have nothing to fear but
fear itself no you're how do you mesh
and reconcile we have nothing to fear
but fear itself
with what he posted on no on whether
it's thursday for me wednesday night was
when he posted this
there's just something about the entire
way he's conducted himself since
becoming a free agent
that rubs me the wrong way because we
know
we know you're not alone mike we know
yeah
we know that he that he wasn't showing
up
at byron left which is house to pick up
a playbook
right we know that the bags he dropped
on the floor of the
house he accidentally walked into had
footballs in them
we know this guy's been doing whatever
the hell tom brady wants to do
right he's got 20 years of football
equity he's got six super bowl
championships
he wants to prove the patriots wrong
he's going to do whatever the hell he
wants to do
because nobody's going to do anything to
him about it and that just kind of
bothers me because it's clear that
there's a set of rules that applies to
him
that doesn't apply to everyone else yeah
i i it bothers people in the nfl
i know that i've had enough people since
this has all gone down
that i think are a little surprised that
you know
the turn the turn of the head by the nfl
by
some of the things that you just
mentioned and all of that and i do i
think it bothers them but you're right
it just doesn't seem like the nfl is
gonna fight this fight or deal with it
and
they got enough issues on their hand
right now but yeah it's just
i get what you're saying it's hard to
listen to that type of message yesterday
from a guy who
you know yes has not seemed to care
about the rules or anything like that so
far as it pertains to this
particular situation still the greatest
quarterback of all time
still still a guy who deserves two hall
of fame bus
one for pre 2008 one for post 2008 i can
separate
the player from these other concerns i
just don't like the way business has
been conducted by tom brady
this year i don't like defying the nfl
pa
it's one thing to not listen it's
another thing
to put it on social media and say look
at me look at what i'm doing yeah what
you're doing
is you're making your union look like a
bunch of schmucks
and now you're showing up three days
later and you're gonna
express support for the union you've
been
undermining i just i i don't like it
i know and i think we made that clear i
like you though i'll miss you tomorrow
i'll miss you on monday hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports